good morning John I just come to the
fascinating recently and I wanted to
share with you in the hopes of you
another people find it fascinating to
and I did not discover it on rent that
is where I discovered most of the
fascinating said I discover but this I
discovered while I was just searching
for songs playing my guitar it's called
the fifties progression popular the
fifties with songs like Earth chill
chill
will you be mine for them popular
afternoon so a like an alternate name
which is the ice cream changes because
it's smooth like ice cream and it's
sweet like ice cream and everybody likes
like ice cream tempura
lactose-intolerant people who hate this
chord progression which is why I like
the name ice cream changes but it didn't
just stop in the 50s as I said it
continued on into the 60s with songs
like do cover and also where have all
the flowers gone long time passing where
have all the flowers gone long long time
ago and I'd like to be under the seat in
an octopus's garden in the shade but I
kept going into the 70s with a song that
was actually designed to sound like it's
from the 50s
I remember when Rock was young meme
Susie had so much fun holding the hands
and skipping stones I had it all go
chatting had a place of my own
but it continued into the eighties every
breath you take every move you make
every bond you break every step you take
got me watching you
and now's the first time it's ever
changed the number of beats per chord
changed in that version in that song and
in the 90s it went from being 2 or 4
beats per chord change to 1 I messed up
she has a girlfriend now she has a
girlfriend now
she has a girlfriend oh she said she has
don't do no more for me and just so you
know no one is exempt you don't love
because I'm not Edward Cullen I can wear
and sparkly makeup and act all brave and
sullen that's right I use the ice cream
changes dude my glasses are falling off
that worked I did the Bieber flip my
beaver flipped it back on
speaking of Justin Bieber
sweeten it up over the two thousands for
our little friends like baby baby baby
oh yeah baby baby
thought you'd always be mine and just in
case you think it's only happy songs
that use this I did by tide and I won
out
so if you said of Fame it doesn't cut
the soul is special fibrin The Reckoning
the sickening package it's a virgin so
the suckers a perversion that was
Slipknot I don't know if there's a lot
of Slipknot fans watching this but there
are high I've been go on they use the
same gorgeous Justin Bieber and then
very recently the most popular song of
the year benefited restitution of
popular and your definition here and
also on your definition of song 7 a.m.
wake up in the morning it just gotta get
downstairs gotta get my book at the bus
stop to see my friends I see my friends
there sit the front seat sittin in the
back seat gotta make my mind up which
seat can i pry date Friday Friday Friday
the weekend weekend Friday Friday this
summons of a Friday everybody's lookin
forward to the weekend
and that was the ice cream changes I
don't know why our brains like these
things but they obviously do John I will
see you on Friday
you